[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
signore e signori giuseppe cura a te
tutto improvvisato come potete
immaginare ma lui piace metterci la
faccia giusto soprattutto come avrei
fatto allora come come introduciamo
questa questa personalità perché tu ne
hai tanta tra l'altro già fatto un teddy
x6 la croce questo nome
da dove arriva allora angeli in realtà
arriva
dal nome russell che era uno dei
primissimi human beatbox air americani
sono stato ispirato che questo nome
perché appunto da razze le a zero
insomma c'è questa somiglianza qui
quando lo conobbi per la prima volta
sulla piattaforma globale di youtube me
ne innamorai e dissi wow mi devo
chiamare in questo modo al finissimo
quindi è fantastico mi da chiamare così
e basta quindi costante 16 al 30 non
abbiamo capito che sei veloce non solo
con le parole
però qui oggi dietro di noi abbiamo uno
strumento infernale che cos'è una loop
station che è quella che collegherà in
maniera tecnologica fra virgolette la
mia performance umana diciamo senza
tecnologia collegato appunto con un
ripetitore
insomma un mixer che riproduce dei
singoli suoni per generarne delle
sequenze musicali
quindi in sostanza tu sei un uomo
strumento prima ci fai sentire come
lavora il microfono e poi lo fai con la
tecnologia propria gente concludo
chiedendo che cosa succede nella scena
italiana del beatbox quanti siete so che
c'è fermento c'è una grande ha presente
l'italian beatbox family che è appunto
la primissima associazione italiana
fondata sullo human beatbox che promuove
appunto di human beatbox air in tutta
italia e siamo numerosissimi quanti più
o meno adesso un numero esagerato un 20
mila a 1 10 eventi che ma credo che
almeno agli eccessivi nascosti quindi in
sé diciamo che si possono realizzare
degli eventi dei raduni organizzati dal
vivo anche online e quindi da è
un'opportunità davvero grossa per
l'italia in sé per questa scena ok senti
prima di lasciare la tua come dire altro
disco nel vero senso della parola latte
dove troviamo social ma principalmente
su instagram del beatbox anche
all'italia di boxe che milita nel box
facebook turbo piattaforme globali
comunque delle solite puzzle a te la
scena dell inaf ei siti di sì sì sì sì
[Musica]
think about
grazie
ok bene è venuto il momento di passare
alla tecnologia la loop station
adesso introduco questo diciamo
movimento tecnico i soliti spostamenti
sapete come si ok introduco questo nuovo
movimento con un violino vocale allora
bing bing bing
[Musica]
siamo
insomma
[Musica]
si può fare
[Applauso]